we wanted to create creatures that we
had never seen before on screen bringing
the magical and sometimes terrifying
creatures to harry potter involved loads
of cgi prosthetics and a shocking amount
of built from scratch functional beasts
say hello to buckbeat
hagrid
exactly what is that we can't be the
only ones who wanted to ride a
hippogriff after seeing harry sore
through the air on the stunning creature
building the hippogriff took a lot of
time and skilled workers as they created
a functioning life-sized buckbeak that
continuously got upgrades the model
included individually cut colored and
glued on feathers it just looked alive
you've just never seen anything like it
the whole animatronic functioned and
could be controlled by radio
buckbeak's adventures didn't stop in
studio though its limits were really
tested when brought out to scotland and
filmed in harsh weather conditions
what we see in the end on screen is a
digitally rendered hippogriff that was
based on the movements and behavior of a
regal golden eagle while the whole
process was extremely challenging it was
very worth it in the end we developed a
motion rig that he would ride which
would actually have the animation
driving it daniel radcliffe really was
facing a giant fire-breathing dragon at
times on set for harry potter and the
goblet of fire a huge and shockingly
real hungarian horntail was made and
placed inside a cage for this particular
image to be captured some of the looks
that you see of peril are genuine the
dragon was equipped with a flame thrower
gun concealed in its mouth so they could
set it off whenever they needed bringing
an amazing image and sound to the scene
the concept artist who initially
designed the dragon extended the
signature horns from its tail up its
entire body creating a unique creature
even more impressive than the one
initially described in the book in in
inventing that he had latched on to
something which is immediately unique
interesting oh my god look at that
creature dementors still give us the
creeps the daunting creature with gaping
mouths ready to suck anyone's soul they
can find while cgi brought the
nightmarish creature to life real
dementor models were created and
experimented with underwater huge
puppets with draping black cloth were
made and with the help of a puppeteer
the team did tests filming the dementors
moving underwater and playing it
backwards achieving their eerie and
unnerving movement we really did pay a
lot of attention to the quality and look
of all of that cloth the troll wound up
being a combination of cgi and a giant
practical figure so the young actors had
as close as they could get to a real
troll to work with one version of the
troll was made as a suit that allowed
for a dancer to get inside and fully
perform ballet as a troll while the
legendary suit didn't end up being used
in the films they still provided a ton
of entertainment for the creature
creation crew dobby the house self will
steal all the scenes he's in dobby and
creature may both have been house elves
but they were obviously two very
different types and in the film both of
them were cgi made luckily they don't
just exist in animation
real models were made of them when
creating dobby the goal was to make a
creature audiences could love and they
certainly succeeded in that the voice
was also a key component in making the
character so endearing dobby is
free
animation only enhanced it all with a
quivering lip and the sweet house elf's
big doe eyes creature of course has a
much less inspirational look creature
and dobby are both elves but you've got
a good version of it
and a bad version of it this gentle
strange and misunderstood creature model
was built and scanned by a laser and
used in the animating of the thestrals
we see in the movie something really
intimidating but mesmeric about it the
cgi did a spot-on job at bringing the
right essence to these characters they
were intended to look grotesque but
wound up bringing a very unique beauty
to the film we're making a kids movie
here
we're not making an indictment of human
cruelty
the living dead brought such deep
sadness and woe to the films but that's
not where they started in the early
stages of design the inferior looked
more like rotting corpses and it was a
bit too gruesome overall ultimately they
settled on more realistic human-like
creatures creatures are the
wild side of the magical world as for
the way they moved dancers and movement
artists were brought into the studio and
directed to move around in all sorts of
different ways
this incredible body language helped
bring out the spirit of the ian fairy
the pixies can be devilishly tricky
little blighters
chris columbus took inspiration from a
prior film of his to create these pixies
their look was based on gremlins while
the students of hogwarts didn't really
get the chance to see these creatures
since they were added with cgi in the
editing phase they were directed in
terms of where the pixies would fly what
they'd be doing and how the students
should react to all the chaos
[Music]
for daniel radcliffe the grindylows
looked like two stuntmen in blue suits
underwater and just sort of pulled me to
in front
these half octopus half humans were
designed and digitally rendered so they
could be added to the underwater
struggle and managed to be extremely
effective
the centaurs seem to
portray the best and worst aspects of
human nature centaurs in the harry
potter world came in many forms
from models to costumed actors to cgi
the road to bringing their final look to
the screen was a long one
they are impossible creatures
actors wearing full centaur gear
including extremely detailed makeup and
prosthetics were filmed to give the base
of the image we would see in the final
cut the models were also used by cgi
artists who added the final touches
digitally to create an incredibly
realistic looking creature a major
reason the mandrake creatures look so
creepy is because of just how realistic
they look this has got to be grounded in
reality shockingly no cgi was used these
puppets wrinkly as they are and covered
with dirt managed to look completely
realistic as they moved the animatronics
were so good that working with them was
extremely easy for the young actors
bringing the werewolf to life was a very
long process
that was
i think the worst nightmare i've ever
had the movie used cgi and prosthetics
in the end but a number of methods were
tried beforehand at one point a full
werewolf suit was built but it was made
to be so tiny and skeletal that even the
dancers brought in to wear it couldn't
move around well due to how restrictive
it was stilts were also part of the plan
in the process but unfortunately the
task proved to be impossible to pull off
realistically instead moulds of the
creature were built to scan for cgi and
the lupine actor had special prosthetics
built for his face and the sneak peak of
his back
that turned out not to be practical much
to my relief because it looked really
very uncomfortable to do that over the
years the looks of goblins have changed
so the first time we see them their
characteristics look pretty crude while
these goblins are very stylized they do
feel real because of just how detailed
the masks were 60 different masks wound
up being sculpted
the way they moved was incredibly
natural and made them feel real but it
didn't come easy the goblins had about
three hours worth of makeup prep
resulting in some very frustrated
performers one goblin literally told
chris columbus that he hated him if
you're doing grey back like these are
all greyback maquettes i mean most of
our characters they start off at
sketches greyback provided the team with
an interesting idea to work with the
character is stuck between werewolf and
humans so prosthetics ended up being
used to create a wolfish look for him
peter pettigrew never fails to creep us
out and much of that is thanks to the
impressive and painstakingly built
prosthetics the facial prosthetics built
for the actor included hair on the nose
and around the ears the creepy rat teeth
added to the whole image making him a
truly disturbing creature to finish off
the look and do the animagus to full rat
transformation cgi came through
knowing many of these creatures were
actually built so the actors could
interact with them makes us wish we
could have been on those sets although
we wouldn't have been too crazy about
facing the larger-than-life aragog and
basilisk either way there was a ton of
real-life magic